der rapper gegen den clan boss bushido
gegen arafat abou chaker zwei die mal
beste freunde fahren und die zu
erbitterten feinden wurden seit monaten
läuft inzwischen ihr duell vor gericht
heute 12 der verhandlungstag kurz
nachdem die ermittler unter anderem das
abou chaker willen grundstück in
kleinmachnow durchsucht hatten
eine schnelle entscheidung der richter
nun das verfahren wird anders als vom
clan wars gewünscht erstmal nicht
ausgesetzt
stattdessen sagt bushido weiter aus über
die trennung seiner frau zum beispiel
ende 214 um die er sich wie auch um
seine kinder damals kaum gekümmert habe
ich ließ meine frau alleine stehen war
ständig im studio oder auf tour über den
tod seiner mutter als sie starb zog es
mir als muttersöhnchen den boden unter
den füßen weg und bushido spricht erneut
auch über sein verhältnis zu arafat abou
chaker bei arafat wurde die religiöse
komponente immer wichtiger er entschied
dass restaurants tabu sind in den
alkohol ausgeschenkt wurde
und er spricht über seinen furchtbaren
streit mit seiner frau anna maria und
über den streit von ihr mit arafat
wir saßen alle drei am chiemsee beim
italiener als seiner frau dann am rücken
der pullover ein bisschen hoch gerutscht
sei habe er gesagt du läufst herum wie
eine [__] und ich nicht weg sagt
bushido als er dann zu hause auch noch
gegen sie die hand erhob sei anna maria
mit den kindern sofort ausgezogen beim
sachen packen seien sie wieder hart
aneinandergeraten sei so laut geworden
dass sie aus dem küchenfenster flow um
dann mit dem landeskriminalamt
zurückzukehren
tiefe einblicke in bushidos leben und in
seinen gefährlichen streit mit dem
kleinbus an diesem zwölften
verhandlungstag
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren